la parole autochtone et six civils sont
morts lundi fuite cette semaine j'ai
reçu une belle question de l aisne qui
me demandent ou devons-nous tracer la
ligne entre une expérience partagée est
le fait de porter un vêtement ou d'être
chiant capteur de rêve chez soi sans
comprendre le sens et l'histoire dans le
fond comment trouver l'équilibré entre
le patrimoine et la mise en tourisme
c'est une très bonne question parce que
c'est souvent un enjeu qu'on parle de
l'été quand l'été arrive et que c'est en
aller visiter des communautés
comment est ce que je sais que j'étais
en train de vivre la vraie expérience où
je suis en train de me faire donner
genre d'expérience ont un petit peu près
marché ou qui va plaire aux touristes
et souvent on peut même parler ici c'est
l'expérience pour le touriste européen
donc une des meilleures manières c'est
vraiment de voir qui offre le service
comment comment tu vas recevoir
justement dont mon apprentissage
souvent tu allais voir tourisme
autochtone du québec
et là tu vas avoir vraiment de
l'information qui vient directement des
communautés qui vraiment des services
offerts par les communautés mais ce
n'est pas nécessairement dire que tu vas
aller dans des communautés éloignées
pour recevoir 6 et ses enseignements de
ces services mais avec tourisme
autochtone du québec déjà tant une bonne
manière de
quand je faisais passer au filtre les
services qui sont vraiment autochtone
est d'origine des communautés qui
origine est comme une excuse on le sait
qu'on arrive en ville que ça devient
plus difficile
qu'est ce qui est vrai qu est-ce qui
peut vrai qu'est-ce qui est dans le fond
un capteur made in china ou qu'est-ce
qui vient vraiment d'une communauté
souvent la meilleure manière de savoir
qu'un produit ou d'un service vient
d'une communauté c'est de demander qui
est l'artisan
si la personne qui te leva ou si la
personne qui t'offre le service ne sais
pas le nom de l'artisan autochtone ou ne
sais pas s'il est vrai que nous venons
habituellement tu parles commencé à
douter un peu de la qualité du service
qu'est ce que tu vas voir
mais les gens sont tellement fiers dans
les communautés de donner leur nom à
leur produit parce que les choses sont
très intimement liés à leurs traditions
à leurs familles que on voit très
souvent à voir le nom de l'artiste de
l'artisan écrit sur le produit c'est
quand même des heurts et des ordres de
fabrication faire tout les objets qu'on
veut trouver donc en acheter
un autochtone tu est sur d'avoir quelque
chose qui est quand même très proche de
la chose la plus originale c'est
certains parents que si tu as quelque
chose qui ressemble à ce que tu penses
être typiquement autochtone sur est de
t'acheter des capteurs de rêves fait en
chine des tipis en céramique
parce que ça va être que tu as vu à la
télé mais faut pas oublier que notre
culture
elle a évolué elle elle se sait quand
elle s'enrichit aussi par rapport aux
avec les échanges qu'on va faire avec
d'autres nations donc faut pas avoir pas
aussi de voir quelque chose qui sort de
stéréotypes dans l'objet n'hésitez pas à
acheter directement des artistes
n'hésitez pas à aller voir directement
les les communautés et surtout continuez
de vous renseigner pendant l'année parce
que ça va enrichir votre visite
quand vous allez voir un site
autochtones quand vous allez voir un
objet technique parce que vous avons
déjà au oui je sais c'est quoi ça j'ai
déjà vu et ça vous allez voir que vous
allez avoir beaucoup plus envie de
l'acheter d'encourager la ccl l'artisan
donc j'espère que ça pu répondre à ta
question
j'espère que vous allez nous envoyer vos
questions un espace autochtone je
souhaite une très belle semaine